hello everyone welcome to another tango
technique class at home i hope you are
doing fine in today's class we won't
need the metronome and we will need
shoes we will do it on our socks because
we want to push with our feet against
the wall and we don't want to
damage the wall with heels or anything
yeah today's class is about improving
the power of our basic steps steps from
side and back the power and also the
dynamic and the balance yeah i'm sure
that you are familiar with this tip
that teachers give you that when you do
a step in tango in any direction you
have to push with your standing leg down
on the floor in order to go into the
step yeah and not only that
when you do the step it also helps to
imagine that you are pushing a
resistance with your free foot for
example if you do a side step
you imagine that you are pushing
something with your free foot away from
you one and this helps to make your step
look stronger more deliberate and it
also helps with the dynamic of the step
because usually when you push something
you start pushing slowly and then you
finish the push fast
yeah if you go back it's the same you
imagine that you're pushing something
back with your free leg or even if you
go front you imagine you're pushing
something in front yeah
so today we will use the wall as a real
resistance for our free leg so that we
improve
the strength of our legs which will
improve how your steps look yeah you
have stronger legs your steps look
better
we will also improve the balance because
you need to hold this push for a while
and you will also improve your core
because you need to engage it in order
to keep this push for a period of time
yeah so this is what we will do today
after the warm up which today has an
extra stretch at the end
um we will use the wall to push with our
free leg in all the basic directions
front side and back and also we will use
the same technique for ocho's front and
not choose back okay
so that's it
um let's go for the one
okay warm up today with an extra stretch
at the end
so start with feet together and take a
few seconds to make sure that your back
is straight your shoulders are relaxed
and down your head is straight and
looking forward your legs are together
and your feet are touching each other
and also they are completely flat on the
ground yeah relax your toes a little bit
and make sure that your feet are
completely grounded okay and we start
with shoulder rotations remember make
the rotations as big as you can and
don't use the elbows don't do this yeah
only use the shoulder okay and we do
eight
one
two three
four
five
six
seven
and eight
now we do arm circles so we move the
arms forward
then up then we open them the hands pass
a little bit behind the back so that you
stretch your chest muscles and then
we lower them yeah and both arms move
the same and we keep the
elbows straight yeah don't bend the
elbows like this don't bend the balls
like this the elbows are always straight
and with weight okay so let's go
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight
okay now we raise one arm make sure that
the elbow is straight and your arm is
pointing up yeah and then
the hand that is uh on the leg slides
down the leg until you can touch the
side of your knee so you need to bend
the other side yeah like this so you
hold the stretch for a few seconds just
three seconds and then you use the hand
that is up to pull yourself straight
again and then you lower the arm and you
repeat to the other side now make sure
that first you have the arm completely
straight up yeah don't bend the elbow
like this and then start sliding down
your leg until you touch
the knee
and then you keep this stretch
and then you return to the vertical and
you lower the arm okay so we do it four
times inside yeah so let's start
one
go down
hold it
and up
lower down
one
go down
hold
it and up
two
slide down the leg
touch the knee hold it
and up
and two
[Music]
slide down the leg touch your knee
hold it
and up
three
arm up go down the leg
hold the
stretch
and up
three
arm up
slide down the leg hold the stretch
and up and the last one four
arm up slide down take your time
hold the stretch
and up
and last time to this side four
go down the leg hold the stretch
and
up underwear down okay now open the legs
a little bit
a bit wider than your shoulder length
yeah
and then bend the knees slightly so that
your hip is centered and looking forward
and straight yeah and then make a circle
with your arms in front of you like this
and then rotate the torso left and right
make sure that your hands
are always in front of your chest
don't move your hands and your arms
further down the chest because then your
torso is not working only the arms so
you have to work with
the middle of your torso yeah you have
to use distortion the arrows don't do
anything the arms move together with the
torso okay
then you are working the back and the
torso and that's what you want and keep
the head straight looking forward don't
look left and right just keep the head
straight okay
and we do it eight times and then again
eight times okay so let's get ready and
let's go
um one
two
six and seven and eight okay make sure
that the hip is always looking forward
that you don't move the hip like this
okay only from the middle of your torso
up okay now we stretch the legs
we put our hands behind the head
and then we bend from the hip
going forward keeping the
back straight until the back is parallel
with the floor yeah and then from here
we drop the head we continue going down
with the help of the weight of our head
and then we bounce three times
one
two three
and then we go up again yeah this will
be a stretch for your lower back and for
the back of your legs okay
so we do it eight times let's do it
together
one
go down
two three
and go up
two
go down
one
two three
and go up slowly yeah
three go down
bounce one
two three
and go up
four go down
one two
three
and go up
five go down
one two
three
and go up
six
go down
bounce one two three go up
seven go down
one two
three
go up
and the last one eight
one
two three
go up slowly
okay
now we keep the legs like they are open
and we grab our hips
we go a bit back with our hip as if you
wanted to um touch the wall behind you
with your bum boom
and then from here you move your hip to
the side you know if you do it right
both legs should be straight and you
should feel a stretch on the inner
muscles of your leg that is diagonal
yeah
from here we go forward
then to the other side now you feel the
stretch on the inside of this leg
and then back to the initial position so
you make a full circle as wide as you
can okay
we do it eight times to one side and
eight times together okay so let's do it
together
one
make it big yeah two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight and onto the other side
one
two
three
four
five make it as big as you can
six
seven
and
eight
okay
now we collect our legs again legs
together feet touching each other
and then we uh
practice our
um
joint with the heel yeah our ankle joint
yeah this exercise is to strengthen your
ankle joint so
you grab your hips if you want or you
can have the arms on your side however
you prefer you bend your knees yeah make
sure that your hip stays straight yeah
then you're gonna do these or or you
know that you that you don't put the hip
back or front yeah keep it straight bend
down bounce three times one two three
then stretch your legs and then go
forward a little bit forward and up on
your toes yeah make sure that your feet
legs don't open yeah keep your legs
together and push down the floor and
lock your ankle joints where you can
stay yeah pay also attention to your
core you should have it
tight and compact okay
so your balance is better and then you
go down okay and then you repeat bend
knees bounce one two three go up go to
the toes wait three seconds and then
down okay and we do it uh eight times
i will put my hands on the hips
go down one two three
go up
hold it
and down slowly don't go down
like this yeah go down in a controlled
way
two
one two three
go up
hold it
and down slowly three go down bounce one
two three
go up
hold it
keep your legs together
and
down four
bounce one two three
go up
hold it
and down
four bumps one two three
go up hold it
and down
five
go down one two three
go up hold it
and down six
one two three
go up
hold it
and go down seven go down bounce one two
three
go up on the toes
hold it
and down and the last one go down bounce
three times one two three
go up
hold it
and down
and now the last exercise is a stretch
for your calf muscles
and the achilles tendon yeah so that's
why it's good to do it without shoes
what you do is i will show you from the
profile because it's easier to see
you start with your feet together yeah
and then you put one foot
in this case i'm going to putting the
left foot forward but you can you can
just start with any side you want yeah
and then basically you go forward with
the torso towards your front leg and you
keep the back leg straight
and the heel of the back leg on the
floor so don't lift it keep it on the
floor and then you find the point where
your your calf muscle and your achilles
tendon are stretching yeah and you hold
it for a while i will hold it for 25
seconds okay
if you are very flexible then you can
move your foot a bit more forward and
then you can go even lower if not then
keep it a bit closer to your back leg
and then just go forward until you feel
this stretch yeah now it's important to
relax the back foot yeah don't make
force towards the floor relax it you
have to put the tension on the knee to
keep the leg straight yeah because if
you bend it you're not stretching so
keep it straight yeah
and
this exercise this stretch is especially
useful if you're a man and you're in
your late 40s or every 50s
our achilles tendon and our calf muscles
become
a bit weak
it's a weak point and this stretch is
very good to prevent injuries if you are
dancing a lot and you are forcing your
calf muscles a lot and also if you are a
woman and you wear heels very often
then your calf muscles and achilles
tendon will tend to shorten you know so
this stretch is very good to undo the
damage and to preserve the flexibility
of your calf muscles okay
so
take this position yeah pull the leg
forward bend it
find the point where you you feel a
stretch
and then i'm going to wait
25 seconds i'm going to count until 25
so 1
2 let it stretch 3
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
five okay
relax the legs
and then
we go to the other side
so start with it together
then put
the other foot forward yeah try to
make a distance that is comfortable for
you
maybe a little bit more
and then bend the front knee
lean forward
keep the backs
legs straight
and keep the heel on the floor
yeah and continue bending until you
really feel a stretch behind and then
hold it for 25 seconds
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
five
okay
great we are done with our map
let's go for the first exercise okay for
this first exercise we will practice our
back step yeah which is extremely useful
for women obviously because you use the
backstab very often but also for men as
well and the exercise works like this we
need the wall so you stand with your
back to the wall
and you keep a distance with the wall
which is more or less the distance of
a normal step yeah more or less
the distance you need for a normal step
and what you do is you put your feet
together yeah you stand straight
you bend your knees a little bit so that
you have better balance and then you put
your weight on one foot for example i'm
using the right foot yeah and then i
move
my left foot back until my heel touches
the wall like this yeah and then i make
sure that my
uh free leg is straight yeah the knee is
straight
and then i keep my axis on top of the
front foot yeah don't go back like this
keep the torso
your axis on top of your front foot and
then you start pushing with your free
leg
against the wall as hard as you can you
push push push push push yeah you should
feel all the muscles
of your free leg working yeah the calf
muscle
the femoral biceps the glutes even
everything that is below your waist
every muscle is hard
and is pushing yeah
and you will also
feel if you do it right that
the more you want to push against the
wall the more you have to push down with
the front leg yeah and this is the best
demonstration i have found yet
of how important it is
to push the floor with a standing leg
when you want to move your free leg into
a step yeah this exercise makes it very
clear because the more you want to push
the wall the more you have to push
around the floor yeah and then you hold
the push and you count for example 16
seconds i will count eight seconds twice
yeah then you relax the legs and then
you do with the other leg okay so let's
do it the first time
feet together bend the knees
then put your weight on the right leg
for example we will use both then move
your foot through the floor yeah until
your heel makes contact with the wall
keep your axis front and then start
pushing with the free leg towards the
wall
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight now you will feel that the harder
you push
the more you have to engage your core as
well so you will train your core and
even your lower back this exercise is
looks very simple but is extremely
complete yeah surprisingly complete okay
so let's do it with the other leg
now i put my weight on the left
i bend the knee
i move my right foot until it touches
the wall
i keep my axis forward and then i push
against the wall 16 seconds
one
two
three
four
[Music]
five
six
seven
eight
okay
relax the legs you need to and we will
repeat it twice more
okay
so
feet together again
put your weight on the right bend the
knee
move the foot the left foot on the floor
touch the wall with a heel
keep your axis front and then let's push
16 seconds
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
now we got our foot feet together
weight on the left
move the right foot until you touch the
wall with the heel keep your axis
forward
and let's start pushing 16 seconds
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
[Music]
eight
ah okay it's hard it looks simple but
it's it's hard
okay relax the legs and we do it one
last time and one last tip is that
when you
after you put your weight on the
right foot and you move the
left foot forward uh back sorry
make sure that you are not opening the
leg yeah
make sure that the free leg is really
behind you yeah
really under the center of your back
yeah don't open okay so here yeah here's
the position
so if you feel that this is too easy
what you can do is to
increase a bit the distance with the
wall yeah because then what happens is
that you have to go a bit even lower on
your knees and you have to stretch
the free leg even more
until you turn to the floor so this is a
bit more challenging okay
let's try last time
let's push 16 seconds
one
two
three
four
five
[Music]
eight
okay i don't know if you see it on the
video but in the last seconds i'm
starting to shake
yeah because the to hold the push is
hard okay so let's do it one last time
backwards
with the
right leg yeah so feet together bend the
knee
and then move your
right foot
behind you exactly behind you until your
heel touches the floor uh the wall and
then let's push 16 seconds
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
good if you did it right
you should feel all the back muscles
everything under under your
waist
um that is worth working yeah
okay great let's go to the next exercise
okay in this exercise the idea is to use
the same principle to train our side
steps yeah so we will push the wall with
our free leg
from the position of a side step but
there is a little problem here if you
place yourself exactly 90 degrees with
the wall like this yeah your hip is
making a 90 degrees angle
then when you make contact with the wall
your foot your free foot will be exactly
parallel with the standing foot yeah
and this is a problem because usually
when you go sidestep you don't put your
feet exactly parallel because it doesn't
look good and it doesn't feel good
usually you open your feet a little bit
like this yeah
so
to solve this problem is very easy you
just
open the angle a little bit more yeah so
instead of 90 degrees with the wall
you are a bit on a diagonal yeah a bit
more than 90 degrees not too much just a
little bit more yeah
and then when you touch the wall then
your feet are open exactly at the right
angle and this is much more comfortable
okay so this is how you do it you place
yourself a bit diagonal from the wall
at a distance of a normal side step yeah
you have to
look for the distance that works best
for you
then feet together put your weight on
the right foot for use left but when i
go to the other side you will see me
going to from behind so it doesn't
matter okay and then bend the knee
and then
make your core tight and compact and
then open your free leg until you touch
the wall
with the side of the foot yeah it's not
just the heel or the toes it's the whole
side of the foot yeah because you want
to push yeah push with the whole side of
the foot okay and then you push as hard
as you can yeah you will feel all your
muscles in your free leg hard especially
the ones on the outside of the leg you
will feel you're
standing like digging down pushing down
on the on the floor
you will feel your core
compact so you can keep this position
and you just hold it for 16 seconds yeah
okay so let's do it together
feet together
and knees
put weight on the right
open the left
and then let's start pushing
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four five
six
seven
eight yeah push as hard as you can and
when you're finishing the count when
you're arriving to eight
push a little bit harder give a last
extra push yeah
okay
then we do it to the other side so i'm
going to turn around and then
instead of 90 degrees i'm going to open
a little bit more yeah a bit diagonal
and then i have my feet together
i bend my knees and my weight now is on
the
left foot and then i open the right foot
until i touch the wall with the side of
the foot yeah you can have your free
food a little bit like this yeah this is
the floor this is the wall and your food
makes a little diagonal connecting the
floor with the wall like this yeah which
is usually what you do when you do a
science that the outside of the foot is
a bit up
yeah so i hope you can see it on the
video i don't touch
the
wall like this i touch it like this yeah
i lift the outside of the foot a little
bit okay
okay and then from this position i start
pushing for 16 seconds let's do it
together
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six seven
eight extra push at them okay i don't
know about you but when i do it i feel
that actually my whole body is uh has
tension yeah
okay let's do it twice more
so
let's use the left foot again
so diagonal with the wall
feet together
put your weight on the right foot bend
your knees
then extend
your left leg until
the foot touches the wall you lift a bit
the outside of the foot
and then start pushing 16 seconds let's
go
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
extra push on that okay
now with the right leg
so
a bit more than diagonal
weight on the left bend the knees extend
the right leg touch the wall with the
outside of your foot
and then let's push 16 seconds
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
and then one last time all fit
you have to adjust your distance yeah if
if this distance is too much for you
then
the closer you are to the wall the
easier it is yeah if you want to
challenge yourself more than you put
more distance yeah but it should be in
my opinion just the distance of a normal
side step yeah a normal size
so for me this is fine
okay so feet together weight on the
right then knees extend the left leg
touch the wall with the outside of the
foot and let's push 16 seconds 1
2 three
four
five
six
seven
eight
and one last time
with the right leg feet together bend
the knees
put the weight on the left and extend
the right until the whole side of your
free foot touches the wall and let's
push 16 seconds
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four push
five six
seven push
eight
okay great
let's go to the next exercise okay in
this exercise we can use the same idea
for our front step yeah so what you do
is the same as before
now you are facing the wall yeah the
wall is in front of you
you find a distance that works for you
you have to try a bit further or a bit
closer what works best for you for me is
a distance that is like a normal
uh too short front step yeah
and then you put your feet together make
sure you're straight and then you put
your weight on the left foot for example
and then you bend the knee
and you move the foot on the floor until
you touch the wall okay
now
there is a little problem because
if the foot goes forward then you are
touching the wall with the with the
front of the toe and that can hurt yeah
especially if you have
long nails yeah so in order to protect
your nails and your toe what i do is i
lift my toes yeah i lift them up and
then i touch the wall with the base of
the toe of the big toe especially yeah
and then this is safe you can push as
much as you want like this and it's no
problem okay and then from here you just
push
forward
as hard as you can for 16 seconds two
things first of all don't move your axis
forward towards the wall because this is
cheating yeah you are putting extra
weight on this leg in order to push now
you have to
be honest keep your axis on top of the
standing leg in every direction that we
use from side back we always keep the
axis on on top of the standing foot and
then you push only from the free leg
nothing more the only other help that
you have is the standing leg pushing
down on the floor yeah and the other
thing you have to be careful with
when you move your foot forward towards
the wall make sure that like we did with
the back step make sure that you are not
using a diagonal that your free leg is
opening
because
it's very uncomfortable and it's not
very effective to push in a diagonal
it's much better to push
directly front yeah directly front so
this exercise on top of all the benefits
that we said before will also help you
clean the directions of your dance it
will help you have very clean directions
for when you do steps in your dance
front side and back okay
so let's do it together
in front of the wall put your weight on
the
left foot bend the knee feet together
make sure that you are moving your foot
right in front of you lift the toes
lift the ball of the foot on the floor
and then push with the base of the toes
especially the big toe keep your axis on
top of your standing leg and then let's
push
16 seconds make sure your core is tight
yeah let's go
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six extra push seven
eight
okay
now let's change the weight weight on
the right
bend the knee
move the left foot forward lift the toes
and
make sure that your leg is right in
front of you not in a diagonal okay keep
your axis on top of your standing leg
and then engage your core
and let's push 16 seconds
1 two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight okay you have to imagine that you
really want to go forward yeah you
really want to go forward but you are
only at the initial part of the step you
are just projecting the leg and you are
pushing as far as you can so relax the
legs and we will do this twice more okay
so
let's go again
fit together if you want to challenge
yourself a little bit more then increase
how you read the distance yeah see how
that works for you
your distance with the wall
okay then weight on the left
bend the knee move the right foot
towards the wall lift the toes then make
contact with the wall
keep your axis on the back on the
standing leg and let's push 16 seconds
one two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three four
five
six extra push seven
eight
okay
now with the other side with the other
foot
weight on the right bend knees move the
left foot forward
lift the toes keep the axis on the
standing leg and let's push 16 seconds
one
two
three
four
five six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six push
seven eight
okay yeah relax the legs relax the legs
yeah you can also try
this exercise yeah
you lift the heel
until the ball is on the floor only and
then you lift the ball until all your
toe is on the floor and then reverse
ball heel
heel up ball up toe
ball down heel down yeah this is just to
relax the foot
in order to be able to do it again okay
so let's do it one last time
feet together control the distance
and then wait on the left bend the knee
move the right foot towards the wall
make contact with the base of the toe
and then let's push
one
two
three
four five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six extra push seven
eight
okay now you got your foot change the
weight to the right
bend the knee
move the left foot forward until you
make contact with the wall lift the toes
engage your core
be careful with your balance yeah
and let's push
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven push
eight
okay
that's it for the front step
let's go to the next exercise okay now
we will use the same principle for the
auto back yeah because when you push
against the wall with your leg with your
free leg you don't have to push always
in straight directions front side or
back you can also push in close
directions
so it works like this
you put your i will show you from behind
because it's much easier to see what
what's going on
so you put yourself side with the wall
yeah 90 degrees now you use really 90
degrees yeah and your distance should be
maybe a bit less than what you use for
the sides yeah so a bit less and now you
put your weight on the leg that is
closer to the wall so in this case it's
my right leg okay you bend the knee and
then you cross your free leg behind you
until you touch the wall with your heel
yeah the ball of the foot is on the
floor
and the heel is on the wall okay
and maybe you need to bend your
standing leg a little bit more than
before to make space for this leg okay
and
then you keep your axis on your standing
leg of course and then you push with
your heel with the whole leg
against the wall for 16 seconds yeah
now when you close the leg behind
maybe your hip will open a little bit
yeah your hip is now
perpendicular with the wall
when you cross the leg the hip opens a
bit diagonal but that's fine
as long as you keep your chest
perpendicular to the wall or parallel to
the wall in front of you if you're in a
corner like this yeah as long as the
chest is perpendicular that's fine okay
so that's how it works let's try
together yeah
feet together a bit closer to the wall
than for the side step
put your weight on the leg that is
closer to the wall the right one in this
case bend the knee
then
cross the free leg until your heel
touches the wall
engage your core and then push for 16
seconds let's go
one two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three four
five
six
seven
extra push
eight
okay
great
now probably you notice why is harder to
push
in a diagonal than it is to push
straight because when you push from this
position
you cannot make as much force against
the wall as when you are pushing
straight yeah
so this is uh an interesting thing to
notice okay let's do it to the other
side so now i will show you from the
front
feet together straight posture
a bit closer than for the side step
put your weight on the leg that is
closer to the wall so the left one
bend the knee so you have a better
balance better grip on the floor and
then cross your free leg behind you let
the hip open a little bit yeah open like
this
until your heel is touching the wall
yeah and the ball is on the floor
okay and then let's push 16 seconds make
sure that your axis is on on your
on top of your standing leg yeah push
down well you will have to push down
there is no other way
okay let's push
and one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven extra push eight
okay relax the legs
shake the legs a little bit if you need
to yeah to relax the muscles
then if you want flex your feet also a
little bit
yeah
and let's do it again
with the left leg so
feet together
distance with the wall control it
put your weight on the right leg
and then bend the knee cross your leg
behind make contact with the wall and
then let's push 16 seconds
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight one
two
three
four
five
six
seven extra push eight yeah
be careful because if the angle of your
foot
is too open yeah too open like this
and it's not enough towards the wall
when you push you you might slide yeah
this happens because
your
heel is too diagonal yeah so you have to
put your foot as much as possible
perpendicular to the floor to the wall
sorry perpendicular to the wall so that
when you push
your foot your heel is really digging
into the wall okay
good so let's do it now with the right
leg
feet together
weight on the leg that is closer to the
wall the left
bend the knee
close the leg the free leg behind make
sure that the angle of the foot is
perpendicular with the wall
put your heel there and then let's push
16 seconds keep your chest perpendicular
to the wall okay
and one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight push
one two
three
four
five
six
seven extra push eight
okay
let's do it one last time both legs
so now to challenge ourselves a little
more we will increase the distance with
the wall yeah a little bit further so
when you
put your weight on the leg that is
closer to the wall and bend the knee now
maybe you have to bend a little bit more
so that you can reach
the wall with your heel yeah
now you have to extend this leg a bit
more it's a bit more challenging so
let's try
16 seconds let's push
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one two
three
four
five
six extra push seven and
eight
okay
it's a bit more challenging when you
increase the distance but this will make
your legs even stronger okay so let's do
it one last time with the right leg yeah
distance a bit more now
weight is on the leg that is closer to
the wall then i open the hip a little
bit actually i don't think about opening
the hip i just think of moving the foot
and i let the hip open yeah the foot is
the important thing you move the foot
and the hip opens as a result
okay
so
bend the knee so you have a very good
bases on the floor keep your axis on top
of your standing leg cross the leg
behind and oh my god this is very fast
okay
until you touch the wall with the heel
and let's push 16 seconds
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight careful with your chest
perpendicular to the wall one
two
three
four
five
six extra push seven
eight
okay great let's go to the last exercise
okay in this last exercise you can try
to adapt this idea for adventure forward
the problem is that
it doesn't really make sense to use this
idea for an actual four because when you
draw not your forward as you know
what you do is first you turn the hip in
the direction of the step and then you
watch the front yeah
so first is the hip
and then is the step
so to train
pushing for the ochre forward would be
exactly the same as to train pushing for
the front step yeah so this exercise is
already good for the electric
but we can use this idea for something
else which is cross yeah cross is
related to the ocean forward in that you
are crossing the free leg in front of
the standing
leg and when you do a cross usually you
don't think much about this movement but
if you want to do a cross that looks
powerful and
strong
you have to use the
muscles of the inside of the leg in
order to close
the free leg
strongly around the standing leg
so you can improve this movement with
the wall with this exercise and how you
do it is like this i will show you from
the front first yeah so in this case you
put yourself with the wall on the side
like we did for the ultraviolet and in
this time you have to
really have a very short distance
between you and the wall you have to be
quite close why because remember we are
training for a cross which is a very
narrow figure yeah
okay and then as before you put the
weight on the leg that is closer to the
wall so in this case is my left leg okay
you bend the knee
and then with the free leg you cross it
in front of the standing leg until you
touch the wall
with the heel okay
the ball is on the floor
and the heel is on the wall
okay and
then from here
you push
through the heel into the wall as hard
as you can yeah it's like you're pushing
sideways through the heel into the wall
you will feel when you push yeah that
you are using a lot the inside muscles
of both legs the standing leg is pushing
down on the floor yeah and the three leg
is pushing on the wall and both legs are
like closing yeah they want to close and
for that you need of course
the inner muscles of the legs yeah so
that's it if you are very close to the
wall and this arm is kind of in the way
and you don't know what to do with it
well you can i put it behind yeah
i i just put it straight behind
and then i have no problem okay
so let's do it together yeah three times
both legs
so
feet together straight posture
make sure that your distance with the
wall is quite short your shoulders
should be almost touching the wall yeah
almost just a few centimeters of
separation
then put the weight on the leg that is
closer to the wall
the left
bend the knee quite a lot this time
and then
just put your arms somewhere that don't
they don't disturb you they are not in
the way and then with the free leg the
right leg cross it in front until your
heel touches the wall the ball is on the
floor yeah and then push towards the
wall with the heel let's push 16 seconds
together okay let's go
one
two
three
four
[Music]
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven extra push eight
okay
it feels weird to push sideways with the
leg but once you get used to it it's a
really good exercise
and your crosses will feel extremely
powerful okay now let's do it to the
other side so i will show you from the
back
so we do the same thing feet together
straight posture and your shoulder is
a few centimeters away from the wall
you put a weight on the leg that is
closer to the wall the right one in this
case bend your knee
and then
cross your
left leg in front of the right
until your heel touches the wall keep
the ball on the floor and then we push
16 seconds let's go
one
two
three
four
7 push eight
okay
great
let's do it again
with the right leg yeah
don't forget to engage your core yeah
and something i like a lot about this
exercise is that when you are pushing i
really feel how the standing leg digs
into the floor pushes really down into
the floor there is no other way to push
with a standing leg sideways to the wall
you have to push down and this is great
because then when you adapt it to your
dance and you do the same
movement with the standing leg pushing
this will improve your damage a lot okay
so let's do it again feet together
weight on the left
very close to the wall
and then cross the right leg in front
contact with the wall and then push
through the heel into the wall 16
seconds
one two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
if you do it right you will even feel
these muscles working above your pump
on your waist this whole lower back is
all is also helping the legs close into
each other and push down and side yeah
okay let's do it another time
with the left
so weight on the right
bend the knee
cross the left in front touch the wall
with the heel and let's put push 16
seconds
ah
one
two
three four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five six extra push seven and eight
great one last time one last time feet
together
weight on the left
bend the knee
cross the right
make sure you are stable core engaged
heal on the wall and let's push 16
seconds
and one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven extra push eight
okay as hard as you can
one last time with the left leg so
feet together
put your weight on the right
and then bend the knee cross the left on
the front
and then
push through the wall through the heel
on the wall 16 seconds
one
two
three
four five
six
seven
eight
one
two push
three
four push hard five
six extra push seven
eight
okay and we are done okay
so these exercises if you uh if you
practice them regularly you will feel
that your legs get very strong very
powerful because these exercises they
practice every direction
so you you strengthen every side of your
leg back front side in out yeah
and also these exercises also make you
very grounded because when you push you
also have to push down with a standing
leg in every direction in every
direction yeah so they will ground your
dance and also they will make you aware
of your posture and especially of your
core because to do all these exercises
correctly you have to engage your core
there is no other way so hopefully that
will translate into your dance okay so i
hope you enjoyed
today's video today's exercises
practice a lot
and i'll see you in the next video bye